passons au chapitre environnement
important ici puisque ce lundi se tenait
à paris one planet summit
de nombreuses figures internationales
par visioconférence angela merkel justin
trudeau le prince charles au tour donc
d'un d'emmanuel mâcon qui s'est posé
encore comme le leader mondial de la
lutte contre le changement climatique
mais quand une greta to bear qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas n'importe qui parle
d'un blabla de puces suivi d'engagements
non tenus qu'est ce que vous répondez
s'agissait d'un sommet sur la
biodiversité et pas sur le changement
climatique
mais ce sommet a été salué par de
nombreuses ong par exemple wwf donc que
greta tout bug soit dans son rôle de
mettre toujours plus d'ambition c'est
légitime
maintenant chacun aidant aussi dans son
rôle faire que quand on est chef d'état
on n'est pas à un conteneur est un
activiste comme greta tout bug et
d'ailleurs certaines ong qui ont
l'habitude et qui sont très légitimes
sur les questions de biodiversité qui
ont l'habitude justement de travailler
le gouvernement comme le wwf ont plutôt
largement salué d'abord ont contribué et
ensuite salué les engagements qui ont
été pris
donc moi je m'inscris dans cette
dynamique positive de façon à ce que mon
adresse
enfin cette question et pour continuer à
augmenter la prise de conscience sur
l'importance de préserver la nature et
notamment l'importance non seulement
pour l'environnement bien évidemment
mais pour notre économie
je rappelle que les les pandémies dont
vous nous voulons parler à travers le
coc vide les dix dernières années toutes
les pandémies qui se sont développées et
bola le strass la grippe aviaire et c
était tout lié à delà du passage d'un
d'un virus du monde animal domestique ou
sauvages à l'homme ça veut dire que la
question de notre relation à la nature
est absolument fondamentale y compris en
termes économiques et c'est pour ça que
les pandémies aujourd'hui nous me
conduise à penser que nous avons
infiniment plus besoin d'action pour
protéger la biodiversité et un message
symbolique qui serait très fort et j'ai
pris la tête de cette campagne en
quelque sorte c'est que le
les scientifiques qui défendent la
biodiversité qui sont les scientifiques
qui sont réunis dans un cercle qui
s'appelle li pé b e s qui est
l'équivalent du giec pour la nature soit
récompensé par le prix nobel de la paix
cette année
pourquoi parce que cette année c'est une
année sur le plan international décisive
pour la biodiversité
vous savez qui l'on recherche
l'équivalent de l'accord de paris sur le
climat en chine au mois d'octobre
et donc si quinze ans après le j acques
les scientifiques du climat
les scientifiques de la nature était ce
v se voyait décerner le prix nobel de la
paix en octobre 2021
je pense que ce serait un message très
très fort qui permettrait de prendre
conscience dans la planète entière que
si la nature disparaît nos sociétés sont
plus vulnérables sont en danger et le
monde entier est peut-être moins sûr
alors c'est vrai que
[Musique]